زلزال يضرب هايتي في عام 2010 في عام
2013 إعصار يدمر
الفلبين
في صراع جنوب السودان يترك أزمة لاجئين
في بنغلاديش ضحايا ماهيندرا
بدون طعام ومأوى كوارث
طبيعية ومن صنع الإنسان عندما تكون هناك حاجة للمساعدة
تأتي من أعماق صحراء
دبي
[  موسيقى]
ما لم تكن قادمة من وكالات الأمم المتحدة ،
نعتقد أن
عضوين من المنظمات غير الحكومية
[موسيقى]
ينظران إلى حجم هذا الشيء
كمدينة إنسانية دولية
تحت قيادة صاحبة السمو الملكي
الأميرة هيا بنت أليس ، يمكننا الحصول على
أي شيء في أي مكان في  العالم في
غضون ثماني ساعات وللأسف
أكثر من 50 ٪ من الآن
المشاكل الإنسانية في العالم تدور بالفعل
حول هذه المنطقة الصغيرة التي نوفرها
لأي حالة طوارئ إنسانية سواء كانت
كارثة طبيعية أو من صنع الإنسان
ونستجيب بطريقة غير سياسية تمامًا
صاحبة السمو الملكي  متزوجة من
صاحب السمو الشيخ محمد بن راشد
آل مكتوم نائب رئيس الدولة رئيس
مجلس الوزراء حاكم ضبا  أنا
سويًا أرسل المساعدة في أي لحظة
للاستفادة من ميناء جبل علي العملاق
يشتري مطارين من الطراز العالمي
لم يكن هناك أي شيء مثل هذا
في الوجود ، لذا للتحدث عن فكرة
وضعه هنا كان أمرًا لا يصدق حقًا
لدينا البحر الصحيح  بجوارنا
ولدينا الميناء الذي لدينا المطار
المجاور لنا يمكننا الانتقال من البحر إلى الجو
في سبع دقائق لنكون قادرين على التسليم
والخدمات اللوجستية نعم ، إنها توقيع
دبي
اللوجستية ، كل ذلك في مكان واحد هنا
كل ما يمكن أن تحتاجه لأي
إسعافات أولية طارئة
وخيام صيدلانية وشاحنات وطعام يجعل
الفرق بين الحياة والموت
وسيلة للبقاء على قيد الحياة عندما تنظر إلى
معظم الأزمات خاصة
الآن مع اللاجئين بمقدار
الأميال التي  عليهم أن يسيروا مع
عائلاتهم لإنقاذ أنفسهم لإنقاذ
أطفالهم ، فهؤلاء هم
المنقذون للحياة ، وكمية القصص التي
تراودك عن اللاجئين ، تريد دبي
الاهتمام بها وخبرتها في مجال الخدمات اللوجستية
إلى  المستوى التالي من خلال ربط مخزون المساعدات في
جميع أنحاء العالم الذي حصل على
ما يقوده خبير لوجستي سابق للأمم المتحدة
2zp Sabah ،
لديك طعام في منطقتين مأوى
حماية المواد التعليمية
الأصول اللوجستية للاتصالات السلكية واللاسلكية والمياه
والصرف الصحي مع التأكد من أن المعونة تتحرك
بسرعة فهي تدعمها  أعلى مستوى من
قبل الحاكم نفسه بمجرد
أن أقول إن برنامج الأغذية العالمي يحتاج إلى طائرة
للذهاب إلى بنغلاديش ، تحتاج المفوضية السامية للأمم المتحدة لشؤون اللاجئين إلى إرسال
شيء ما إلى عنتيبي في
غضون دقائق.
معروف ببريقه وبريقه الآن لمساعدة
ضحايا الكوارث الذين فقدوا كل شيء أنا
فخور حقًا بما يفعله
وما تفعله الحكومة الإماراتية وما
يسمح
لي به ويساعدني على النوم ليلًا ولكني
لا أفعل  لا أعتقد أن أيًا من القادة هنا
يشعر أنه بإمكانه أن يربت على نفسه
ويقول إنه عمل جيد.
طبيعة ما نتعامل
معه لم يتم إجراؤه جيدًا حتى
ينتهي